we sat there and i remember you telling
me something because i don't think you
talked about on the podcast last time
but you you talk about the third act
your life is an axe and i remember you
getting
really descriptive about that yeah tell
me about the acts
the pandemic just pushed it over the
cliff it just pushed me fully into act
three um you know the idea was
i did the rat race as an actor for a
long time
worked for all these phony companies
same with you we toured a lot
we've done all kinds of stuff and you
sense yourself
and this is only me speaking for myself
not the entrepreneur that you are
always reinventing yourself oh yeah i
found myself
entering a rinse and repeat phase of my
life and career rinse and repeat another
rinse and repeat uh you know meaning
it's you're going to wash your hair the
same way again and
you're going to rinse it and repeat it
the next day and so
conventions started to be very
uh similar and ubiquitous and working on
certain types of tv shows
certain types of entertainment became
boring and kind of annoying and
uh you know television was exciting and
new
um back in the day and
i'm sure there's still great stuff but
the tv grind uh the last
tv series i did ash versus evil dead
i was like okay i think i need to like
quit
i think i need to quit i need to go suck
my thumb on a mountaintop somewhere
because i bur i just burned myself
out uh at too late of an age i was like
i could do a show
you i could still got a tv show on
me and you know we ground out three
seasons
and uh you know i left a piece of my
soul there
and you still we had a lot of creative
control but you still don't have the
control that
that i have in act three act three it's
my own publishing company curtin media
um i'm putting out my first book the
cool side of my pillow it's a book of
essays
and you go oh snorrisville man and
that's cool
but it's it's my it's my book um if it
blows it's me
i'm i'm i'm the guy and as a result if
it does okay i'll reap the reward so
i also came to a horrible realization
during this pandemic break the first big
lockdown period i was like
wait a minute movies are too expensive i
can't i can't do this in my backyard
i need to i need to do stuff that i can
literally do in my backyard so
my to-do list is a is a new book didn't
cost me anything to write it
and i've written a couple of screenplays
and now and i'm
i'm doing a my first comedy album called
the lost recordings
all right hang on first of all you're
glitching a little bit your voice is
fine which is fine but your body's
your face is glitching a little bit like
you're a little well i'm on a
mountaintop
i can call you back but you know is that
that's kind of this is about as
this is kind of what we get up here
that's it all right well i think we
should stick well now you now your eyes
are closed but
we'll uh hold on hold on i wonder if you
could do this for me kidding
i was kidding oh you bastard i believed
you yeah
your acting isn't done your acting isn't
done sir